nous venons de regarder mana groupe
journal de bord bonsoir si vous nous
rejoignez sur tv 78 alors ce
documentaire a été réalisé par loïc
l'église et peggy rice qui sont avec
nous en visioconférence et également
avec nous la metteuse en scène nicole
mondiaux bonsoir à vous trois alors pour
apple un documentaire et retrace la
saison 2018-2019 d'une troupe d'artistes
de 12 à 70 ans et dont la moitié est en
situation de handicap
ils se réunissent toutes les semaines
aux mureaux ma première question
concerne le nom de ce groupe qu'est ce
qu'un malade groupe nicole mondiaux mais
en fait un certain inspiré de de la
spiritualité
ça c'est la force spirituelle d'un
groupe en fait manama et ça vient de la
polynésie chez lehman aubry voilà et
pardon c'est un groupe qui existe depuis
quand on a commencé à travailler en 98
et donc peu guérissait l'oit l'église
comment vous en êtes venu à réaliser ces
documentaires j'ai rencontré ni le
condiment 2016 travail dans la
production dans le pays akyé
j'ai accompagné une école qui change de
certains de ses projets et j'ai
rencontré la troupe mois de temps après
notre rencontre dans le travail et on a
eu le haut mais stéphane avec loïc 2017
il me semble et l'idée du documentaire
est venu dans la foulée de ce premier
spectacle qu'on a vu de cette troupe et
nicole points de lyon en tant que
chorégraphe et metteur en scène vous
êtes au contact de la troupe très
régulièrement
qu'est ce que ça vous apporte à chacun
en porteurs d'un handicap ou non
tous ces échanges ces interactions
beaucoup d'humanité en fait en le
le groupe existe depuis 20 ans et pas
forcément les mêmes évidemment depuis
vingt ans les plus anciens sont là
depuis une dizaine d'années et moi ce
que je sens je sens beaucoup de
solidarité et je sens le pour hope
tellement fort que il accepte aussi tout
temps des personnes nouvelles
il ya quelque chose il absorbe les
personnes nouvelles et comme je
m'inspire beaucoup de effectivement
c'est un as tu un aller-retour pour
construire votre spectacle
justement vous parlez de personnes
nouvelles dans le groupe
dans le documentaire vous dit que il ya
eu certains qui se sont greffés
notamment des parents est ce que c'est
une façon aussi pour ses parents ces
familles de se rapprocher de se
redécouvrir
oui c'est une façon de vivre aussi autre
chose avec son enfant et pas être
toujours comment dire être le parent
responsable
ils se retrouvent tous les deux en train
de travailler au même niveau et c'est
donc oui c'est une autre façon d'une
autre relation
ce qui peut se créer entre eux et on
voit dans le documentaire que certains
sont plus bavards présent affirmé que
d'autres on voit baptiste qui joue
presque avec la caméra est ce que
justement cette caméra elle a permis à
certains d'être plus à l'aise ou au
contraire il a fallu s'adapter loïc
église
il a fallu il est encore en douceur on a
été taclé très vite comme les et nicole
et y avait un climat de confiance du
début
maintenant c'est vrai que batimat et le
début jouer avec sa caméra y avait un
enjeu
pendant ce premier jour de ce sens là où
par exemple romain ou d'autres
était beaucoup plus timoré quand il
voyait la berge s'approchaient d'eux
évidemment il avait quelque chose d'un
peu intrusifs pour eux et puis passé
antique de l'année on est trop serré
mais il a fallu voilà bien évaluer ses
distances à prendre et comment vous avez
fait justement pour les mettre à l'aise
du coup je pense qu'il ya déjà eu la
force de le fait qu'on se soit vu
régulièrement donc une familiarité qui
s'installe un peu
nous on avait un dispositif de tournage
à cvg pense qu'on était pas trop
impressionnant ou en tout cas pas pour
trop longtemps et qui vaille à 103 2 6 3
stations qu'on peut avoir entre 2 et le
fait qu une école aussi a beaucoup
oeuvré à ce qu'on soit bien acceptée a
expliqué ce qu'on faisait peser
voilà je pense que deux des changes
aussi autour de ça et simplement le fait
de zoua pas régulièrement je pense que à
partir de là les choses s'accélèrent
facilement surtout il sans donner des
membres de magath de manas groupe
en fait à chaque fois quelqu'un arrive
qu'ils apportent de la musique ou qui la
porte du théâtre ou la vidéo
il devient membre et je pense que c'est
ça qui fait que le mana voile a été
restituée et mana groupe c'est comme un
coeur qui bat il faut trouver sa
pulsation alors cette phrase c'est
annick baumann qui l'a dit dans le
documentaire
nicole pfund uk ce qu'elle voulait dire
par là bas c'est risible convient de
dire effectivement parce que ce coeur
qui bat en fait ça chaque pulsation ses
coûts de chacun est important pour que
ça puisse vivre voilà donc c'est pas
parce qu'on est
peu plus timide et qu'on parle pas et
qu'on est dans un coin on a besoin de la
pulsation de cette personne là on a
besoin de tout le monde on a besoin et
de baptiste et de et d'autres personnes
qui sont beaucoup plus timide un groupe
pour faire un nous eh ben il faut
plusieurs heures lundi
si ce que vous avez ressenti un loïc
loïc et pays
c'est un groupe soudé vous avec un
regard un peu extérieur du coup moi je
pense que si je vous ai donné envie de
faire le film si bien dire en commençant
à travailler avec eux c'est c est
dynamique de groupe qui avait avec des
personnalités extrêmement différente des
âges extrêmement différents et si je
pense qu'on a essayé de rendre à travers
ce chine et ce film justement est-ce
qu'il a été vu par tous les membres du
groupe
pas tous parce que en attente de pouvoir
le présenter au ciné par stade eric
dahan euros
il était prévu donc au mois de janvier
on est en quelle année là 2021
voilà donc évidemment abssi nema pour
l'instant donc ça va porter et sur les
retours que vous avez pu avoir de ceux
qui ont pu le voir
qu'est ce qu'ils en ont pensé login
mais les membres et la troupe
vous voulez dire à une brouille due à y
en a aucun qui l'a vu d'accord ok bon et
ben hassel suspense est donc plus
personnellement à la fois loïc et ep10
vous vous êtes resté donc une saison aux
côtés de la troupe
qu'est ce que ça vous a apporté
personnellement moi j'ai ressenti en
fait comme une bouffée d'air parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya une mentalité dans
les relations et
un naturel qui qui pour moi était très
porteur étonné donné envie de les
retrouver et souvent quand on regardait
les rushs en rentrant le soir il y avait
quelque chose de enfin envoyé quelque
chose d'à la fois de très drôle et assez
touchants moi je trouve ça très agréable
oui c'était une très belle aventure et
puis qui s'est très bien passé ce qui
s'est bien terminée puisque caen est
ressorti donc évidemment pas encore
montré autant qu'on l'aurait voulu en
tout cas pas un principe pour concernés
mais ça ne saurait tarder et puis à un
titre encore plus personnel pas c'était
une première collaboration avec avec p
10 avec bédié nicole de cette nature là
elle qui est un problème gym donc c'est
bon c'est ces importants projets qui
nous emmènera j'espère à d'autres
projets et est ce que ce film vous
voulez le présenter à des concours des
choses comme ça oui on a commencé dans
le film a été terminé indécence 2020
donc c'est encore assez récente et on a
commencé à les envoyer à kouyaté des
festivals essentiellement et un peu
aussi autour de nous de france on a
commencé à envoyer des festivals
thaddée cinéma art et essai et on espère
notamment pouvoir présenter l'année
prochaine en seine-saint-denis lier un
projet qu'on a deux teintes et revenir
en atelier au sein d'autres
établissements qui accueillent des
personnes en situation de handicap et
essayer de faire des croisements essayer
de faire connaître on puisse voyager
présenter s'il rencontrer d'autres
personnes en situation d'handicap qui
font du théâtre et nicole point de vue
alors ce documentaire il a été tourné en
2018 2019
on voit que la danse passe beaucoup par
le toucher les échanges comment ça se
passe depuis un peu plus d'un an avec le
co vide pendant continuez donc enfin on
a repris en septembre jusqu'au
confinement du mois d'octobre
et moi je pars du principe que on est en
bonne santé
donc tant qu'on était en faisait très
attention avoir les mains propres mais
juste où mon travail c'est de leur
donner confiance
on n'est pas nous malades
non on est là on n'a pas de symptômes
on va bien et on essaie de créer du du
bien-être comme ça maintenant on est en
visio depuis avec certains on ne peut
pas l'être
et donc je téléphone régulièrement à
chacun d'entre eux et on attend vraiment
de revenir mais quand on reviendra
il faudra que je prenne du temps pour
remettre cette confiance en place
remède se toucher en place et ses rires
et les expressions du visage parce que
moi je travaille vraiment sans masque
voilà et sans barrières donc je pars du
principe qu'on va bien voilà ep
guérissent le 8 l'église donc vous avez
suivi les répétitions pendant toute la
saison du début jusqu au spectacle final
pour vous qui était bas spectateurs à la
fois des répétitions et du spectacle
comment c'était ce point final peut-être
l'oit enfin le jour du spectacle comme
le dire vraiment excitant c'est ça qu'on
attend et puis et puis ça arrive en 2
voilà de l'excitation dans l'air un peu
de stress aussi deux de tension
c'est très émouvant parce que c'est
l'aboutissement ça qu'il travaille
pendant un an
et puis là c'est là où ils prennent le
plaisir comme digne c'est pour ça que
c'est pour ça qu'il répète c'est le sens
qu'il donne à sa cellule pour être
applaudi c'est aussi pour montrer ce qui
est ce qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont
construit tous ensemble
c'est ça passe vite
j'ai l'impression en tout cas pour eux
ça doit passer très vite on nous fait
passer assez vite aussi comme journée on
avait des plans importants à faire
on était dans les coulisses je pense que
c'est important de démontrer ses
coulisses et on avait voilà quelques-uns
pour ça donc assez stressant aussi de
notre côté mais les réjouissances
d'assister à cet aboutissement est donc
ce projet un plusieurs années du coût du
début des répétitions jusqu'au projet
final un bilan aujourd'hui peut-être
peggy de toute cette aventure besoin
d'ajustements l'impulsion pour d'autres
pistes a priori on est parti pour des
que la troupe pourra nous vous répéter
un projet vidéo qui intégrerait la
scénographie du prochain spectacle
on est aussi avec de nouvelles idées par
rapport à mon cher à la manière de le
montrer et de faire que la troupe puisse
en parler
donc voilà je pense que ce qui nous
amènera envie de tirer les fils en tout
cas de cette aventure evonik aux
mondiaux donc ça fait 20 ans est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter encore 20 ans
de plus oui j'étais en train de me poser
des questions voilà jusqu'où
comment encore mais va tant qu'il ya de
la vie il ya de l'espoir on va dire ça
marche
merci beaucoup à vous trois pour votre
présente ce soir loïc l'église et peggy
rice et je rappelle que vous êtes les
deux réalisateurs nipple mondiaux la
chorégraphe et danseuse c'est la fin de
ce sept huit sociétés merci de nous
avoir suivis la semaine prochaine un
nouveau moment d'échangé de discussion
bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]